CARTER MORGAN: Did
you hear the news?
I heard that Critter
Junction got a fever,
and the only prescription
is more services.
Let's take a look
at how we helped
Critter Junction turn their
monolith into microservices.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
While much of Critter
Junction's focus
has been on redesigning existing
systems to be more scalable,
they also had to have
a plan for new systems.
They wanted to add a
level editor feature,
and instead of using C++
like the main game engine,
they wanted to write it in a
designer-friendly scripting
language like Python.
This led them to wonder
if it would be a good idea
to break out all of
their core services
into independent
services, and if so, how
should they go about it?
When our team first took a
look at Critter Junction's
architecture, we
told them the truth.
Not everything needs
to be a microservice.
Microservice apps add
complexity because how
the independent services
communicate can be non-obvious.
And that communication
happens over a network,
so message passing and
security can become a concern.
Plus, just by better
architecting your monolith
to include monitoring, logging,
CI/CD, and health checks,
you can get a lot
of the benefits
of a microservice-based
approach,
like observability
and recoverability.
For their level editor
feature, Critter Junction
needed the ability to deploy
services independently
and for separate teams
to write components
in different languages.
So for their needs,
a microservice or
service-oriented architecture
gave them the most flexibility.
We thought this would be
pretty straightforward,
but we ran into a problem.
While some of their services
didn't require state,
some of the services
clearly did,
and some services were
tightly coupled in a way that
made it unclear if they
actually required state or not.
Ideally, you want your services
to be stateless and not retain
any local persistent data.
This way, each
request or interaction
can be handled without needing
to know what happened before.
This approach makes
it a lot easier
to scale and recover
your services,
because services can grow,
shrink, or be restarted
without losing any data.
Luckily, before we started
refactoring the system,
we took the time
to create a plan.
The first step was to take an
inventory of the entire system.
We spent some time
refactoring the monolith
to decouple some
of the components.
While this was going
on, the new level editor
was designed and deployed
as a microservice.
This was great because
it gave Critter Junction
a preliminary test for the
new approach, where they could
set up and test deploying
services independently
and make sure they can
communicate with each other.
Then we started migrating
the monolith in stages.
Instead of doing
everything at once,
we started with the stateless
components, like the UI.
After the stateless
components, we
went on to migrate staple
services with independent data
sets, like their auth
service, which wasn't as easy.
Finally, we migrated trickier
features with shared data
sets that we couldn't
quite fully decouple,
like their shopping
cart feature.
Over time, Critter
Junction can work
to re-architect these
features, but for now, they
have a functional and
more easily maintainable
microservice architecture.
Transitioning from a monolith
to microservice approach
isn't always necessary and
it isn't always effortless,
but in this case, it
gave Critter Junction
key business
features they needed,
so it was the right choice.
So that's a wrap for this
episode of "Season of Scale."
Stay tuned to learn how
Critter Junction continues
to improve the design of
their app architecture and dev
processes.
And, remember, always
be architecting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]